point lead and you sense curry and the  warriors moving in for a little bit of a  kill here  steph in his bag deep  like the fries were at the bottom  [Applause]  now  [Applause]  on to the warriors you know jordan poole  gets an offensive rebound and steph puts  that home  and then gets to look at the crowd and  again  [Applause]  you're sending multiple defenders at  them give it up get it back  but average touch time for steph curry  is  minuscule compared to the other great  scores in the game  he doesn't need to keep the ball in his  hands  for that long this time he's dancing  with it melton  gives him just enough space this guy is  just he is  magnificent light work  for steph curry it